Ever wonder why childhood summers lasted
forever, but now years vanish in
seconds? Here's the disturbing truth. By
30, you've already lived through half of
how long your life will feel. Your brain
literally takes fewer snapshots of life
as you age. That feelgood chemical that
helps you track time, it decreases every
decade after 25. Think about your most
vivid memories. Most happened between 15
and 25, right? That's because your brain
was recording everything then. Now, your
mind has a skip button for your daily
routine. Here's what's terrifying. The
better you get at life, the faster it
passes. Your autopilot is stealing your
time. But there's hope. Want to slow
time down? Start living like a tourist
again. New experiences force your brain
out of efficiency mode. Time isn't
moving faster. You're just sleepwalking
through it.